やっぱ料理するつタイプ見た目が入らなきゃいけないからねばカッコアートで行き
ましょうこんにちははじめ社長ですお前ら応答コードを持っている条件何かわかるか
総料理ができるかできないかでござる知っての通り僕はですね実際を全然しないんです
けれども
そのきっっっっいたちょっとキッチン大きくなったんで今日は自炊で何か作ってみよう
かと思う
ます僕につける料理はのめちゃくちゃなのでひょっとしたらねマネして食中毒になら
れると困るので
的家でも真似しないでくれを意識できたら女してい netgear イベント
ちょっと本当に何にもダメですけども
とりあえず料理を作ってみようと思いますレシピとかも何も見ずにもトレースねなかっ
たり剤がっぽいのもあるんでちょっと感覚でね
料理作ってみようと思いますでは
どうぞこちら
でしょどうぞ玉ねぎの皮をむきますあまり良いそう言ってもドロアついてそうだから
まず所三者
プロがついて欲しいんだけどね3つだった後の接続の皮を剥いてあげましょう
たまにはこのなんか目としたが毒を持ってるって聞いたことないから
赤で食べちゃダメなんですよ誰かが言ってた
これはね駄目なんだよこれは食べちゃダメです危ないんでこういうからやりましょう
ただこれぐらい向ければ良いと思いますそこで玉ねぎをも言ってる間にもうね
クライバー尾根しましょうくらいバッグ猫外で食べてくる前に行っちゃならないんじゃ
水だけ紅茶なってから寝ちゃっていきますこれでバッチリ綺麗になった
このフライパンにそのままですするためないからちょっとだけサラダロータスわけです
よ
コースも塗ってもし何かをやることになってもこれを下に付
あるっていうそういう性質があるんです油には大前ですランチくらい真似しましょう
c ぞ
ジュージュー言ってるパンツまで葉山まぁこれでクライバーよしでしょ
このフライバー金されてる間に俺は玉ねぎをみじん切りにします
[音楽]
さぁなんでなんでなんです残念です
何で割っ日
さあ何で箸町俺のしてラベルは罰ロスならないよ弱火に弱火狙い本取れの真似してみ
ましょう
言うぞうん上濱ネギをなるべく細かく進みますちょっと多すぎただな
ブーバーし
ねなぜ焦げてる俺の知らないとこで何が起きている
ああ
どうせ何かすぎてね何このこけちょっとおかしいな調子あるいは
car
ゆっくりだった
関西本線ネイマール超つける音ですよねティムくねっすかねちょっと物理したねそれ
もう1回器を取り出していきましょう
なんでサーバープラグなんかんだよって僕には分からない
やっぱ料理青木がすごいねもし今会社名非月です
よしじゃあこれを早速やすっていう ok で先ほどみじん切りした玉ねぎ4敗8
さらにハムを
ちょっと大きいなってあげようちょっと大きいので切ってあげましょう
で下山ハーボーちょっと端ザメに切手をまぶします
ok こんな感じですこれでもだいぶゲストはそれました
ああああああ
費用このままだと味金がないのでここで使用後者を打ち込みます
生んだよねぇ知ってる
[音楽]
ワイヤーここで様に投入します
a 様放談回富士山としてください grep みたいな感じです
サーモンっていきましょう
[音楽]
味付けにコーナーよりましょう v 争い切れることでまた数が変わります
あーその指ちゃったら微妙な技がおいしさの一過程があります
言ったぞさーいここに隠し味です
トマト&ガーリックここでトマトソースをちょびっと言いましょう
よしこれで加熱咲いてほしいよ
もうなんかん何すればいいかわかんないしあなたがタマゴってくるなんだこれでもいい
感じだぞ
千葉こそつけますつけたしましょう
うわぁ私はこれなんなに作ってるんだろうなこれにさらにあとご飯を作ります
便利な世の中がそうするべきだろうなお皿に移しましょう
me
これは意図うまそうな気がするのはただのスクランブルエッグに入ってきたなこれ
貴族をかけましょう
てきたん
できる者もです
もう一個欲しいところおばあちゃん2匂いがするこれは別々に行くんじゃなくて
これは混ぜて書かせますよねこの後愛の作ったんですけども
このさっき作ったはじめの特製の料理を打ち込みます
これをちょっとこう混ぜ合わせます
[音楽]
me
あった
ちょっと待っていっ
オムライスじゃねこれをむ大豆じゃん失敗完成しました
田添した長身生活の初の手料理でございます
こちらこの後何を払いすです
を燃やせになるとは思ってなかった
[音楽]
uh
エプ2でお会いして本当に限りなくおいしい限りなく美味しいけども
お前大事です